for much of joe biden's political career
he and his wife jill's incomes
stayed pretty consistent as a senator
biden brought in about 155
000 a year with about 20 000 on the side
from a teaching gig at weidener
university
jill earned about 60 000 a year from her
job as an english professor
at delaware technical community college
becoming obama's vice president got joe
a pay raise to about 225
000 a year for two terms and jill's new
job teaching at northern virginia
community college raised her salary to
000 a year there were a few boosts here
and there
for example one coming from the literary
agency sterling lord litteristic in 2005
which paid them just over 81 thousand
dollars
but it was after biden left the white
house in 2016
that he and his wife were really able to
cash in big
leveraging their fame to sell books take
on teaching gigs and deliver speeches
the biden fortune ballooned within four
years of leaving
office the couple earned 17.3 million
dollars
and have a net worth of around 8 million
but take the 17.3
million in earnings and subtract all
11.8 million of the couple's known
expenses
such as taxes charitable donations
housing costs
you're left with 5.5 million however
biden's disclosure shows cash and
retirement accounts worth
1.2 to 2.9 million far less than 5.5
million
which leaves about 2.6 million elsewhere
so where did it go well one possibility
is gifts to family federal tax laws
allow couples to hand off
thirty thousand dollars per year to
anyone without having to report it
the bidens could have also given money
to charities outside the u.s
which wouldn't show up on tax returns
another possibility is
they just spent it the couple did
install a new pool
at one of their homes in 2017 which was
estimated to cost
over 75 000 in 2019 the washington post
also reported the bidens were renting a
five-bedroom mansion in mclean virginia
for about twenty thousand dollars a
month and as for the eight million
dollars they're worth
how does that break down well much of it
is real estate
the bidens owned two houses worth over
four million
dollars together one being a delaware
beach home worth an estimated 3.4
million
joe biden also receives a federal
pension which guarantees him
annual income of about 160 000 for life
other wealth sits in cash accounts state
retirement accounts
life insurance policies and holding
companies
surprisingly not much of biden's fortune
is tied to investments
the president has made pledges not to
invest in individual stocks to avoid
ethical conflicts
and a 2019 financial disclosure showed
less than two hundred thousand dollars
in mutual funds